is the neighborhood when Lauren Chavez
lost her life nearly two weeks ago now
those who loved her saying they want to
share her story with Las Vegas she was
just a great person days after her
sudden death Those Who Loved Lauren
Chavez remember the person she was she
always was laughing and giggling and
making jokes Lizette Cortes her best
friend of 17 years describes the 41 year
old as the life of the party and says
she's still shocked by how her life was
taken
police say Lauren was murdered by her
husband who then killed himself at this
home near MLK and Carey leaving their
15-year-old son behind and Lizette says
while her family is grieving they also
want to spread awareness her parents are
just angry and sad at the same time
because of how it happened Lauren's
death was one of several murder suicides
to happen within a week and they want to
encourage anyone else in a domestic
violence situation to ask for help I'm
on the news now talking about my best
friend being murdered
because of domestic violence you don't
want to be that person this as they try
to come to terms with what happened
while also holding on to Lauren's memory
it was hard to know that this was
happening to her every single day from
this day forward don't let it come to
this don't allow it to come to this the
family does have a GoFundMe up right now
to help with funeral expenses if you
would like to help out reporting in
North Las Vegas tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now
now Lizette says Lauren's son was not
hurt and is now safe with family if
you're experiencing domestic violence
there is help you can call or text
safenest 24-hour hotline this number at
the bottom of your screen there
702-646-4981